[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale nous sommes jeudi 14
mai
c'est un géant de la commercialisation
des espaces publicitaires et de mobilier
urbain
le groupe français j'essaie déco
implantée à plaisir n'a pas été épargné
par la crise sanitaire du coc vite 19
avec une diminution brutale de son
activité à partir de mi mars et un
chiffre d'affaires quasi nul au premier
trimestre le groupe a enregistré une
baisse de 14% de son chiffre d'affaires
des équipements assurer un service
d'astreinte
jcd cossette ensuite mobilisé en
permettant un accès gratuit aux
personnels soignants à ses vélos en
libre service avec la reprise le groupe
a relancé ses premières campagnes
publicitaires à partir du 13 mai avec
des règles sanitaires pour ses
collaborateurs
nicolas landry a interviewé christophe
bertrand directeur régional jcd qu on a
quelques annonceurs qui ont souhaité
reprendre la parole très rapidement ça
monte en puissance un sur les prochaines
semaines on s'attend quand même à ce que
ce cela se passe sur plusieurs mois pas
avant la fin d'année pour revenir à un
niveau qui était celui d'avant
confinement mais on s'en est en tout cas
on accompagne nos annonceurs et on
essaie d'être inventif là aussi pour
repenser avec eux les modes de
communication dans l'espace public ce
qui est sûr c'est que la ville elle
n'existe pas sans commerçants activité
économique qui a pas de vie en sont ces
acteurs-là la rue reprend sa place là ça
sent on a mis en place autant de
protocole sanitaire que de métier il ya
énormément de métier de notre entreprise
donc chacun est formé avec les bons
équipements de protection individuelle
avec les bons gestes pour pouvoir aurait
intervenir dans l'espace public
réafficher des campagnes à la fois de
municipal des campagnes commerciales
remettre en état aussi des mobiliers et
dès demain pour retrouver un 7,8 et coke
établira un bilan provisoire de cette
crise sanitaire et abordera la reprise
économique du secteur yvelinois reprise
également pour les artisans pour qui la
situation peut parfois être compliqué
ils sont accompagnés par la chambre des
métiers et de l'artisanat
nicolas landry a posé trois questions au
président de la chambre des yvelines
[Musique]
la chambre de l'artisanat effectivement
est en appui de tous les artisans
yvelinois c'est à dire 22 mille artisans
aussi bien nous avons 80% de nos agents
qui sont télétravail ou équipés de
téléphones avec des ordinateurs
portables pour tout ce qui est
réglementation qui sont en train de
sortir et tout les avantages fiscaux que
l'on peut essayer de deux d'avoir et
donc nous sommes en appui des artisans
d'une façon générale
[Musique]
pour certains pas bien du tout puisque
effectivement il ya des fermetures
administratives purement et simplement
je dirais comme exemple direct qui nous
intéresse tous aujourd'hui ce sont les
coiffeurs par exemple où là on leur a
demandé de fermer purement et simplement
il y en a d'autres qui s'en tire un
petit peu mieux comme les alimentaires
boucher le boulanger et je suis par
exemple chez les bouchers que ça se
passe très très bien pour eux puisque
nous avons quand même par le biais du
confinement beaucoup de gens qui mangent
chez eux et donc
en gros chiffre d'affaires en plus
[Musique]
pour certains il n'y a pas eu de
confinement puisqu'il continue ils ont
continué à travailler
il y en a d'autres qui ont eu un
confinement partiel c'est-à-dire que
comme pour ma société nous avons un
atelier donc les gens d'ateliers travail
puisque les fournisseurs ont joué le jeu
et ont continué et par contre j'ai
commandé du chômage partiel pour mes
poseurs et puis par contre effectivement
pour les autres c'est fermeture totale
donc là c'est une très bonne chose que
l'on ait une date quand même qu'ils
puissent dire ça y est on redémarre à
telle période donc s'armer quand même un
coup de baume au coeur
vis-à-vis de ceux qui vont pouvoir
travailler car il ya quand même une
besoin de faire du chiffre d'affaires
puisqu'on a quand même deux décharges
qui sont en train de tomber aux
spécialistes des machines de production
pour l'industrie numérique l'entreprise
quatre visions implantée à guyancourt a
vendu des imprimantes 3d et fournit des
procédés techniques plusieurs clients
comme l'assistance publique hôpitaux de
paris ou le technocentre renault
objectif répondre aux besoins face à la
crise du colis de 19
reportage de nicolas d'andré des
imprimantes 3d pour produire des
visières des pièces pour les
respirateurs ou encore des tirs portes
pour quatre des visions distributeurs de
ces technologies implanté à guyancourt
la crise sanitaire n'a pas été de tout
repos
l'entreprise a notamment fourni 60
machines à l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris
quand on voit à l'échelle de l'ap-hp
c'est les 60 machines qui ont été
disposés c'est pas loin de 5000 pièces
qui sortent par semaine en fait les
techniciens de 4 des visions sont aussi
intervenus au technocentre renault de
guyancourt des ajustements techniques
sur des imprimantes 3d déjà présentes
sur le site industriel des machines
utilisées pour la production de 10 hier
et de pièces pour respirateur avec le
fabricant on a fait un travail de fond
pour essayer de trouver une solution à
leur ouvrir on va dire la machine
pendant la durée du coc vide à tunis en
ce matière qui serait capable d'être
avec ses 7 ces matériaux assez
spécifique au delà des diar s'est démené
toute la partie dispositif respirateur
en fait où justement on avait un besoin
d'eux
d'avoir une biocontact biocompatibilité
et avoir justement des materi qui plus
est réalisable la collaboration avec les
groupes industriels du territoire une
activité habituelle pour quatre des
visions dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire les échanges avec les clients
étaient centrées autour du principe de
solidarité
l'opération est parti de pologne s'est
étendu en belgique espagne et jusqu'en
france
elle s'intitule voter pour nos héroïnes
le principe des bons cadeau offert au
personnel soignant pour des coupes chez
le coiffeur des soins esthétiques et
encore des cours de yoga et de sport une
ambassadrice dans chaque département est
chargé de récolter ces bons auprès des
professionnels de la beauté et du
bien-être pour les redistribuer ensuite
céline michel esthéticienne à
centraliser plus de 300 dons pour le
moment dans les yvelines dans les
hôpitaux dans les dons va dans tous les
établissements hospitaliers on l'a
remarqué leur souffrance leur manque de
moyens la façon dont ben dis donc je
devais travailler dans les siens quand
les circonstances dans lesquelles ils
devaient travailler on s'est rendu
compte maintenant pour la plupart des
gens que c'était difficile mais le
problème c'est que les soignants sont
dans cette situation depuis fort
longtemps
il a fallu qu'ils essaient crise pour
qu'on puisse se rendre compte
ben à quel point il souffrait dans leur
travail et on a décidé effectivement de
leur rendre hommage et d'essayer de leur
donner ce moment dit de détente
on essaye de leur apporter pour
qu'effectivement il puisse après ces
prises ces heures qu'ils ont fait ces
visages fatigués effectivement leur
apporter le maximum de repos de détente
fins qu'ils méritent en fait
l'opération est à la recherche de
nouveaux bons cadeaux pour les soignants
et également d'un prestataire pour
imprimer c'est bon si vous souhaitez
vous joindre à cet élan de solidarité
les contacts s'affiche en bas de l'écran
un personnel soignant toujours en lutte
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus 457
décès sont recensés dans les hôpitaux
des yvelines au décompte du 13 mai un de
plus en 24 heures les hospitalisations
sont elles en baisse et 25 personnes de
plus sont rentrés à leur domicile elles
sont 1675 depuis le début de l'épidémie
c'est l'un des premiers sports à pouvoir
se pratiquer en ce début de
déconfinement le golfe
les trois sites de saint quentin en
yvelines ouvrent à nouveau leurs portes
pour le blue green attrapé le golfe
isabella à plaisir c'est uniquement pour
les membres et abonnés ce qui n'est pas
le cas de celui de saint quentin en
yvelines
reportage de wilfrid richy et nicolas
landry comme le vélo ça ne s'oublie pas
mais bon les réglages sont difficiles à
j'espère que je vais pas perdre trop de
balles aujourd'hui remise en route
difficile pour les golfeurs amateurs
d'autant qu'il faut maintenant composer
avec le respect des gestes-barrières
ouvert depuis le 11 mai le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à repenser
sa façon de fonctionner on peut comme
avant jouer à quatre personnes
on ne peut pas venir plus de 30 minutes
avant son heure de jeu qu'on doit
obligatoirement réserver et également on
doit
donner un sens de circulation à ce que
le maximum de clients ne se croisent pas
du tout donc on a fermé
l'accueil des clients green fille au
niveau du pro shop et on a créé ce site
accueille éphémère dans le grand hall
qu'ici à prête parfaitement donc les
gens rentrent du parking dans un sens et
puis ils repartent dans un autre pour
aller sur le parcours après ils peuvent
un parent visiter le pro shops ils ont
des besoins d'achats et aussi en a mis à
disposition une seule toilette
il ya certains endroits sur le site
qu'ils ont complètement condamné tels
que les vestiaires qui ne rouvrons pas
jusqu'à ce qu'on a le droit sur le
parcours il est dorénavant interdit de
toucher au drapeau ou d'utiliser un
râteau plus de bancs ou des poubelles
également les yeux de barrières on y
pense obligatoirement mais on y va pour
le plaisir on fait attention aussi à ces
gestes barrières heureusement qu'on est
un sport de plein air et qu'on n'est pas
un sport où on est l'un sur l'autre
donc voilà on fait partie des
privilégiés qui peuvent reprendre leur
pratique sportive des produits après au
golf et c'est rare qu'on est con soit
l'un sur l'autre sur le parcours on
arrose plutôt à droite à gauche donc les
esb arrière on y pense obligatoirement à
des contraintes mais pour la direction
une satisfaction néanmoins celle de
freiner les pertes financières durant
les deux mois de confinement ce sont 20
% de perte du chiffre d'affaires qui ont
été estimées pour revoir les
professionnels foulé ce green il faudra
en revanche attendre encore un peu à
l'open de france 2020 prévu en juillet
ayant été annulés un peu de musique pour
terminer cette édition avec un artiste
yvelinois nous l'avions rencontrée lors
de l'inauguration d'un foyer de jeunes
travailleurs à versailles ce mail
profitent de déconfinement pour sortir
demain son premier projet musical
il répond aux questions de grégory
cannabis ce sera dans les bacs ou plutôt
sur les plateformes digitales demain
vendredi 15 mai yoga un premier ep pour
vous sommeil bonsoir bonsoir
alors comment tu avez vous déjà en cette
semaine de déconfinement basse et une
semaine un peu festive rapport aux
déconfinement et puis aussi un rapport
ben à la sortie de cette paix de mon
premier parrain de mon deuxième clip
pardon aussi
donc voilà plein d'événements assez
sympa alors peut-être titre pour ce
premier projet musical dont la sortie
et était prévu plutôt pourquoi avoir
repoussé cette sortie au vendredi 15 mai
c'est en quelque sorte votre cadeau de
déconfinement c'est un peu ça oui il ya
le fait que par rapport à la crise
ben ducobu de 19 on avait une release
party qui était prévu une grosse soirée
avec une bonne salle mais bon bah
forcément les concerts est un compromis
il a fallu se diriger vers une sortie et
puis digital en fait et donc qui
interviendra demain vendredi
cette période où vous êtes restés
confinés pendant deux mois à versailles
au foyer jeunes travailleurs dans lequel
vous résidez ce qu'elle vous a permis de
réfléchir peut-être de changer l'artiste
que vous êtes est ce que ça vous a
permis un petit peu de réflexion cette
période de confinement oui complètement
c'est vrai que on s'est dirigé vers
quelque chose qui était plus digital les
réseaux en fait ça a été tout naturel et
on a mis en place des challenge on a
fait des vidéos de cover aussi sur
youtube
donc voilà ça nous a permis vraiment de
communiquer avec une fanbase bas qu'on
n'avait pas suffisamment sollicités
avant quoi avec eux qui étaient très
contentes de découvrir toutes ces choses
qu'on avait envie de partager avec lui
en fait avec quatre titres pour cette
paix dont dis-moi pourquoi dont le clip
est sorti il y à peu on écoute tout de
suite un extrait
[Musique]
je ne veux plus vivre comme ça
le vivre comme ça
moi
je perde
manger sain terre disposés sur un
ça
là
quand c'est emma
autant je suis
[Musique]
dis moi pourquoi un clip ensoleillé
soleil tournait dans votre martinique
des sonorités entraînantes c'est ça
votre style pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas ou vous avez déjà reçu
ici en plateau mais pour ceux qui ne
vous connaissent pas c'est ça c'est un
style entraînant sommeil oui c'est ça
les paroles peuvent peut-être
nostalgiques ou un peu profondes aspirer
à la réflexion mais c'est vrai que
j'aime garder un style très très
entraînant à une musique très dynamique
c'est quelque chose qui me tient
vraiment à coeur
il ya quatre titres sur cet ep est ce
que sur les trois autres on est dans la
même veine
oui alors il ya assez de relief quand
même hein on a des morceaux qui sont un
peu plus triste des morceaux qui sont
très joyeux comme le dernier morceau
index majeur voilà donc c'est ouais il
ya beaucoup de relief et donc c'est déjà
le deuxième clip qui sort de sept pays a
dit moi pourquoi il y en avait aussi un
autre qui était sorti auparavant
oui absolument c'était amy attend qu'ils
étaient donc du coup le premier single
qui était paru en novembre novembre 2019
et un clip 20 un très très beau clip
tourné en bulgarie une très belle
opportunité aussi à vous prévoyez quel
autre pays pour les prochains clips
ben franchement si ça peut perdre et
j'ai le plus possible c'est vraiment
super c'est une belle aventure sommeil
et j'espère que ça va continuer et
prendre de l'ampleur et justement
l'objectif avec cette sortie de paix
c'est la poursuite de votre projet
musical
on avait discuté sur ce plateau du début
de ce projet cessé de le poursuivre
c'est une nouvelle étape finalement oui
complètement basset a vraiment là je
montre vraiment qu'est ce que c'est
sommeil avec un premier rhdp et c'est
une base pour construire encore plus ce
projet et proposer des choses qui seront
encore plus proche de ce que je suis
vraiment et de ce que j'ai à proposer
quoi est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
dernière question alors ben que le live
reprennent assez vite parce qu'on a très
envie de retrouver le chemin de la scène
et puis voilà un nouvel album en
préparation donc voilà votre première
paye aux gars disponible donc à partir
de demain vendredi 15 mai sur les
plateformes digitales merci sommeil
d'avoir est avec nous merci à vous
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve dès
demain pour un nouveau rendez vous avec
votre actualité locale bonne soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
à